[MUSIC PLAYING]
W. BARKSDALE MAYNARD: Princeton is
of national, and even
international, importance
as a landscape.
Princeton is not
just a pretty place,
but it is a place of
tremendous history.
A place that really deserved
to be protected and preserved.
I went through 7,000 historic
photos of the Princeton campus,
studying innumerable
pictures of trees.
Trying to identify which
trees in the old photos
are still standing today,
and it turns out several are.
Several trees that are 100,
150, even 200 years old
still stand on the
Princeton campus.
MERC MORRIS: Trees are a part
of the fabric of the campus,
and they carry
forward one era to
the next, much like buildings.
But like us, they don't last
as long as the buildings.
So trees impart a
memory to the campus.
When you come back
to campus, you
remember how you felt when
you were here as a student,
but it looks different.
Well, the buildings haven't
grown, the grass hasn't grown,
but the trees have changed.
And that's what makes the
difference in the mood
and the feeling of the campus.
W. BARKSDALE MAYNARD: Around campus,
as you walk around,
you'll notice many of
the trees have labels.
That's just been done by
the Grounds Department.
And they've done a terrific
job of labeling these trees
indicating the
names of the trees,
the species of these trees.
There's interesting information
about all of the trees.
It's great to know the
difference between a Wych Elm
from Scotland and the American
Elm, native to our forests.
And they grow side by
side on Front Campus.
So these trees have now been
labeled, and that's a big help.
MERC MORRIS: I like
to look at trees
as to what they bring
to the campus in terms
of botanical uniqueness.
This particular tree behind
me was planted in 1948.
And it is comparatively
young, compared
to many of the trees on campus.
Yet it may be one of the tallest
of its kind in the world, which
is a botanical curiosity,
and also speaks to the health
and well-being of
the trees on campus.
W. BARKSDALE MAYNARD: Three of my favorite
trees are on Cannon Green,
and they're these tremendous
Ash trees, enormous Ash trees.
And we know from old photographs
that Cannon Green was densely
filled with trees at the
time of the Civil War.
So these are three survivors.
Three trees that were
planted in the 1850s,
and are still there growing
on Cannon Green now.
When you see the great Sycamores
in front of Maclean House,
we know they were
planted in 1766.
Those are the very same
trees that George Washington
saw when he came here
for commencement.
Those are the same trees
that James Madison saw
when he was doing graduate
work in Maclean House.
Extraordinary, that those
are the very same trees.
They sprout new green
leaves every spring today,
just as they did for
George Washington.
That's remarkable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]